and today the head of the government of Ukraine and the first
lady of Ukraine represent our state
in the United Kingdom where the
Coronation of King Charles II and Queen
Camila took place
from the division of the entire Ukrainian people, I
congratulate their majesties, true friends of
Ukraine, with this historic event that
begins a new era of the British monarchy, I
wish the king the eyes of the zones  to the third, long
years of successful rule and
prosperity to the people of the United Kingdom and
victories shared with us. It was an
honor to meet personally with his
majesty in London. I remember our
conversation. I remember the sincere emotion for
Ukraine and Ukrainians and Thank you for your support.